The mobile systems are mobile devices.
What are mobile devices?
Well, it's all of our devices.
Mobile systems are mobile devices.
What are mobile devices?
Well, it's all of our devices that are mobile.
Things like our iPhones, our iPads, our little mini-super computers
that we keep in our pockets that store gigabytes, maybe even terabytes of data
and are unbelievably powerful little computers.
So what's the risk with these mobile devices?
Well, it's the fact that they can store so much data nowadays
and the fact that they're mobile.
Because what inevitably happens is someone puts a bunch of data on this device
that probably shouldn't be on there.
And then they forget their device somewhere inevitably in the cab,
in the airport, on the train.
Let's talk about an example of this actually occurring.
And it highlights just what the risks are with mobile devices.
So there was a healthcare provider in the US, I think it was in Minnesota, in 2011.
A employee of that company left their laptop in their car.
The laptop had about 20 million records on it, on about 23,000 patients.
And they left this laptop in their car when they wanted to do a Starbucks or something like that.
And what inevitably happens, the laptop was stolen.
There was a whole series of extremely unfortunate events that all occurred
because of that lost one lost laptop.
So what happened?
Well, there was a lawsuit by the Auditor General.
There was a giant settlement, millions of dollars with the Auditor General.
Their CEO, COO, CFO were all fired and replaced.
There was two class action lawsuits from patients whose data was potentially exposed.
There was a settlement with the FTC.
Over 170 jobs were cut.
And as a final kick in the pants, they were delisted from the New York Stock Exchange.
They were publicly traded company.
All of this, all of these tragic events occurred because of one lost laptop.
And then companies never recovered.
I've checked on their stock price a couple times since then.
And they've never recovered.
They've never gotten back to the highs they were once at.
And they don't actually exist anymore.
They were bought out.
So this whole tale of woe was because of one lost or stolen laptop.
So let's spend a minute thinking about this.
What would be the best way to have prevented this event from occurring?
This lost or stolen laptop?
And all the horrible things that happened afterwards?
About a lot of you were thinking, hold drive encryption.
They should have encrypted the entire contents of the hard drive.
Because the whole idea behind hold drive encryption is, even if someone steals your laptop,
they'll find that all the data is being encrypted.
And don't get me wrong, hold drive encryption, excellent idea, defense and depth,
have multiple layers of controls, all good.
But there's actually more of a flaw in hold drive encryption than most people realize.
And that is, while the hold drive encryption is amazing, it'll use, you know, like AES,
256-based encryption, it's unbelievably difficult to break the encryption.
But the problem is, if someone has stolen your laptop,
how long do they have to figure out how to break that encryption?
And do they, in fact, need that extremely difficult to find 256-bit key?
No.
What they, in fact, need to unlock that excellent encryption is the user's password.
And how good are our user's passwords?
Horrible.
The most common password in the world is password.
So an attacker that steals a laptop that has hold drive encryption
has an unlimited amount of time to try and discover probably a very bad password.
And you might be saying, oh, but lots of laptops have protection mechanisms that only allow you
to try a password so many times.
Well, those mechanisms are pretty easy to defeat if you have physical control of a laptop
of its in your possession.
So hold drive encryption, not a bad control, but not the best way for preventing this.
Okay.
What about remote white capabilities?
Lots of cell phones and even some laptops have the ability to remotely wipe the device.
Again, not a bad control, but not as good as most people think.
Because what's required for that remote white capability to be activated?
The device has to be sent a signal and the device has to receive that signal.
And he's skilled attacker.
Soon as they steal a laptop, what are they going to do?
Well, they're going to put that laptop in a fair day cage,
in an envelope in something that's going to block that signal from being received.
And then when they get it back to their criminal layer and their parents' basement,
they're going to put themselves in this fair day cage.
And so that laptop, is it ever going to receive that kill switch that signal to wipe the drive?
Of course not.
Now, for reasons, I decided to look into this a little bit.
I thought, you know, let's find out how expensive it is to get one of these sleeves
that you can put a laptop in a fair day cage, essentially.
So I went on Amazon and on Amazon.com, like 2030 bucks, you can get a nice haul quality one.
I was like, that's pretty good, not too bad.
Then I was like, I bet you can do better.
So I went to Alibaba, straight from China, right?
On Alibaba, as long as you're willing to buy like 500 of them,
you get them for like three bucks a piece.
Pretty darn good.
But then I thought, you know what? I can do even better.
So it turns out, bag of chips.
If you open up a bag of chips, you see that silver lining inside, it's mylar.
It's a pretty good blocker of radio waves.
So you go to Costco, buy yourselves a jumbo bag of chips, you got snacks,
you got the fair day cage you need, there you go.
You can defeat the remote wipe capability.
So what's the best answer for how we prevent this type of mobile data breach?
The best answer in fact is to not have the data on the laptop.
If there isn't sensitive data on the laptop, then there's no worries about that laptop being lost or stolen,
which is inevitably going to happen.
So it turns out, one of the best ways of preventing these types of breaches is policies,
procedures, user awareness training, and education,
so that users know not to store highly sensitive data on their mobile devices.
So when we think about how do we reduce the risk of mobile devices,
one of the best ways is through policy, education, awareness.
And then of course, do have the other physically and the other controls in place,
still a very good idea, defense and depth to have things like whole drive encryption,
to have remote wipe capabilities, to have good anti-malware capabilities, whatever.
You know, still use all those controls, but the best one, training and awareness.
Now let's talk about a couple of other controls that are really important to have with mobile devices.
And we'll get into how you secure the connection between mobile device and the device itself at a moment.
But one other thing we should spend a moment on here is if you're writing an application
that's going to be used on a mobile device, which is very common nowadays,
writing apps and web apps for phones and laptops and things like that.
There's a really good set of guidance out there.
A top 10 list of the top 10 things you should probably avoid when you're creating your mobile application.
So there's an organization out there that probably many of you have heard of,
a WASP. They do a really great job of investigating mobile devices,
web applications, things like that, and figuring out what are the top 10 security risks
that cause the vast majority of the breaches. And they've created a mobile device top 10,
and it's listed here on the screen. Don't need to memorize it, but do know what you could use something like this for.
And the use of something like this is if you're developing an application or a group within your organization
is developing an application, they should be very aware of things like the OOS mobile top 10.
And they should be making sure that the application they're creating is not vulnerable to any of these top 10 things.
Continuing on the concept of policies related to mobile devices.
A couple of major policies you should have related to mobile devices are things like an acceptable use policy.
What mobile devices can and can't be used for? For organizations that allow employees to bring in their own devices,
their own phones, you should have things like BYOD or CYOD policies.
Bring your own device. I always think it's BYOD, bring your own booths, but that's totally different thing.
So BYOD is bring your own device, CYOD carry your own device. These are policies that define if someone's bringing in their own personal device,
requiring, for instance, certain security controls be there from a corporate perspective,
making sure the phones aren't jail-broken, that they have a whole drive encryption, that sort of thing.
And it's also a good idea to have a policy around personal computers.
And in my opinion that policy should be, no personal computers allowed, it's very, very difficult for an organization to know that a personal computer is secure.
There's so many ways to install, backdoor is an unintended, you know, things on a laptop that a corporation does not want to bring into their environment.
Now when we think about mobile devices, the whole point of having a mobile device is you can use it wherever you are anywhere in the world.
And often we are connecting that mobile device back to our corporate network.
And we're transferring data back and forth between wherever we are in the world and the corporate network.
And where is that data transiting? The internet. The biggest hive of vile scum in the world, right?
I mean, it's the internet. No traffic going around across the internet should be secure traffic, unless that traffic is encrypted.
So an important security control to have with mobile devices is to encrypt the traffic between the mobile device and the corporate network.
And while we often use for this, our solutions like VPNs, virtual private networks.
And we'll talk about VPNs in a lot more detail in the networking domain.
The final consideration is the security of the endpoint itself, even if you have the most secure connection in the world.
An attacker is still going to know all the sensitive data if they have control of the endpoint if they've somehow installed a backdoor or malware on the phone or the laptop.
So the final major piece of mobile security is how do you actually make sure that the endpoint that the laptop, iPad, phone is actually secure.
And that's that we use that concept of hardening, right, where you go through whatever the appropriate security controls are to disable on an unnecessary services,
close unneeded ports, install anti malware, all those sorts of things.
And you should do that for any of your mobile devices that you're using out there.